today I'm going to tell you about the
secret mark which shows if somebody is a
properly initiated chemist if they've
really been through the experience of
becoming a chemist
I'm in the lab where primo levy the
famous Italian writer and chemist used
to work we're really lucky is going to
be refurbished in one or two days time
so with the last people ever to film in
here and primo Lavery in one of his
books wrote a famous story called the
mark of the chemists so it's not really
a story but it's more an essay about
what it's like to be a student doing
chemistry and he has this idea that
chemists are rather like Freemasons or a
guild of artisans who all learn to do
the same trade to make chemicals to turn
one thing into another and what he says
is that every chemist has a special mark
on their hand to show that they're a
chemist and the way that mark came about
is like this nowadays when we join
chemical glassware together they have
ground glass joints and they just fit
together rather like because he says
like Lego or some sort of construction
kit but in the old days people used
corks or rubber bands and you had to put
glass tubing through it so what you did
was first of all you made a hole using a
special tool called the cork board and
some people say the cork board was the
greatest invention for chemistry in the
whole of the nineteenth century and then
once you'd made the hole you had to
force the glass tubing into the hole so
what people had to do and the way the
mark of the chemist was formed was to
push the glass into the hole and you can
see it doesn't go in at all easily and
very often it would slip and the piece
of glass would go into the chemists
finger but because most chemists -
right-handed according to Prima LaVey
the mark would be on the chemist
left hand just about there but I'm
left-handed so I ought to have a mark
here now I don't have one either because
I was lucky or perhaps because I didn't
do it enough but the point that Primo
Levi makes in his story and the one I
think throw the fan is that all chemists
know that it's dangerous doing this but
nobody used to tell the young chemists
of the danger just so they could go
through this initiation ceremony of
sticking the glass into their hand for
themselves nowadays I'm a safety officer
so I have to tell people like you to be
careful but it is surprising how many
modern chemists still have accidents
sticking pieces of glass into their hand
you